would you rather everyone be naked all
the time or clothed all the time
full all the time I guess how are we
gonna have to naked all the time how
many other people you see in a day I
think you'd get used to it I think it's
like when a bad smell you get used oh
I know like someone's just dirty hanging
in your face like all the time well you
know what it'd be nice you just know
what you're getting before you go in and
so much of my anxiety around hooking up
is like what are they're gonna be like
like not that it needs to be big but
what if it's just like a weird
and then you would just know yeah balls
are balls you can ignore but like it
just like sometimes it can be so
frightening and I know this can be the
same way so yes I would like to naked
stand by